my name is sadiq khan it's my pleasure
to be hosting this glamour
unfiltered special to mark one year
uh since the kobe lockdown began and i'm
really
humbled to be joined by dawkis and
sue
i work in a royal free hospital as a
nutrition nurse
and my role involves just reviewing
patients who need long-term feeding so
either finding the right human for them
um and then throughout the peak of the
pandemic i
am volunteer is the nhs nightingale
as part of the redeployment program
so my job changed from working 9-5
to doing long days and working an ic
unit
that i have never worked before and the
redeployment program is really
just basically going into a different
area offering your skills and then also
being open to receiving new skills
sue i know you played an important role
in keeping that city going to
enable key workers like dawkis and
others to go from home to work
and back home again share with us what
your job what your job is both
before the pandemic and how your job
changed during the pandemic
before my current while i say transport
support and enforcement officer
with tfl i worked as a revenue
protection inspector
for the buses um
in my current role which became a
property of as of
april 2020 um the
tse role is primarily focused on
tackling anti-social behavior
on the network and supporting frontline
staff in the face of workplace violence
and
aggression uh while whilst
also being a visible reassuring presence
but all staff and travelling passengers
and to help keep the network
and people and passengers safe i'm lucky
i can do my job working from the safety
of my home
i don't need to go out when it's unsafe
to do so
and i don't need to do so but i've
at times not felt my best i think my
mental health has suffered a bit
uh in relation to being at home being
isolated
and the challenges of the pandemic just
just don't talk about them if you
feel it's personal but have there been
times where your mental health has been
affected where you've
had issues in relation to how you're
coping
uh i want stalkers first and ensue and
if it's
if you have what sort of things have
helped you get through this
during the people i remember like being
really anxious
to sleep and just like hearing like
machines because like you're wearing
an ic unit and they're like shoes and
your ears and whatnot
and then i remember when i was able to
completely rest this is when the first
weight
i was being able to breath just really
really
reflect about obviously what i've gone
through
and i thought how can i go back to an
icu unit
if we did have another way
and the fact that i was constantly
anxious thinking about this i knew that
there was something wrong
so during the first wave obviously i
went back to destructive behavior which
was either like
you know just overeating or not eating
enough
just to surround that and i remember
just saying that i can't do this again
so when i was asked to go back to icu
during this parent way i had to say
no i had to just really be honest with
them and say
actually i can't do this and
unfortunately for me i was little to do
and i am apparently having some
psychotherapy
um which is which is helping i guess i
wanted to
challenge the whole concept of what a
strong woman was meant to be
because people will see nurses or you
know
doctors or you know people that work for
um
national public health and things that
were really really strong
the strength doesn't really necessarily
mean that you can't be vulnerable
and for me talking about this and
talking to my colleagues about this
actually gives me that strength to
realize that i'm not i'm not alone and
really challenge that topic perception
of what
you wanted to be thank you for sharing
that uh so how about you what what sort
of pathologies have you
if any gone through over the last year
or so i've been
having some form of um
anxiety about my own safety and
well-being being
on the front line every day um
[Music]
i'm endearing as as everyone else
to government guidelines as best as
possible
[Music]
and my home is like mentioning when i
finish work
and i post my door behind me i i switch
off
i um can do something simple like
read a book play some music
um and i also have two rescue cats which
is very
therapeutic and relaxing i've seen the
last year some amazing acts of
uh londoners you two are a good example
of giving me hope
and really raised my spirituality
nuggets all stories about things over
the last year that have really just made
your day and just giving you hope and
a sense of optimism going forward
i remember everyone just thinking that
this patient wasn't going to make it
and then a couple of months went by i
think it took about
three months i went on to a ward to see
another patient i saw this patient being
discharged and walking out of the
hospital
and i remember just starting you know
started leaving and i just thought
this is why we do what we do this is why
we work for the nhs to see people
leave and actually be healed or you know
be well
and yeah i would never forget this story
and i can just like
vividly remember it in the midst of
uncertainty
there's been a lot of like fear and a
lot of pain
maybe a lot of people are hurting but i
really just want to convey
this message just to say that we need to
take our mental health as a priority
um and for someone who's been so open
about how i'm feeling
now i think it's really important for
people to just talk about the message
because it is a shared
shared thing that we're all going
through so
yeah please please please just get some
help
if you know that you need help and you
know it's not shamed upon we're
celebrating this
because you're being open and you're
being bold and it's that courage that we
need
and i think that would be my message
really listen
to donkeys can i as the mayor of london
uh thank you for being extraordinary
over the last uh uh 12 months uh i mean
one of the things that inspires me as
mayor
is meeting brave women like you doing
amazing work and for
those watching this glamour unfiltered
special to mark
the one year anniversary of this
lockdown i'm sure you've inspired them
as much as what you've inspired me and
on behalf of londoners
thank you so much and stay safe
thank you